any single person who does that man or
woman it's gonna make your dating life
easier how could you offer thousands of
dollars of value you could I would
approach a woman and if she was not
enthusiastically into me I would say
nice to meet you have a nice night but
what if she was extremely attractive so
maybe this is where Tate actually comes
in handy can I ask how much you made
from the book
um
thank you so much for coming in the Ace
coffee really let me say that again too
early
coming on the iced coffee hour we really
appreciate it I'm a huge fan of your
book The subtle art of not giving an F I
am someone who gives an f about too many
things I overthink everything this book
was recommended to me or it came up
someone sent it to me I can't remember
exactly how I came across it I read it
and it completely changed my mindset in
terms of what to prioritize what to give
an f about and just I guess life in
general about kind of letting things go
which I'm really bad at so for that I I
thank you and I'm so grateful for you to
come on I appreciate that yeah when did
the desire to become an author start uh
uh maybe like late 20s late 20s 27 28.
so it was I I'm assuming after you spent
plenty of time introspecting and kind of
like fostering the current philosophy
that you have kind of yeah I you know
there's a funny there's a saying with
writing which is um
um
writing imitates life so you need to
like go out and live
um I think I spent most of my 20s just
like living and trying a bunch of [__]
and I never knew I was a good writer I
got bad grades in my writing classes and
at the time I thought I was like oh I'm
just not a writing guy I'm like a
science guy
but looking back it was because I didn't
follow
the the assignment you know they would
they would tell me like write a piece
exploring the thoughts of George
Washington or whatever and I would like
write a fan fiction that imagine that
George Washington was an alien and
planted to like bring democracy to Earth
and uh and I get like a [__] F
because they're like this is not what we
assigned and I was like oh I guess I'm a
bad writer then like you know it didn't
even occur to me until I was like 30
then I'm like oh wait
maybe that's actually what made me a
good writer is that I didn't follow the
assignment I didn't write like exactly
what people expected of me so it wasn't
actually until I had started my
uh
uh online businesses and started
blogging and got a lot of traction
blogging
and started getting all these emails of
people being like man you're an
incredible writer like you should you
should write a book sometime that I was
like huh maybe I should write a book
sometime what were you blogging about
initially so a bunch of things so I
started my first I read four hour work
week in
2008 that's when I first read it too
when it first came out yeah
um I remember
yeah I remember uh
my the one real job I've ever had I
worked at an investment Bank in Boston
and uh hated every second of it and I
remember I had four hour work week under
my desk
and any like little break I got I'd pull
it out and read a few pages and I just
remember by the time I got to the end of
the book I was like I gotta get the [__]
out of here I gotta build a website or
something like this is
I can't do this so I started a handful
back in 08 after reading a four hour
work week I started a handful of
very crappy kind of e-commerce affiliate
marketing websites
um and back then if you wanted to get
traffic to those websites
you blogged like blogging was the big
thing it was what Google loved
um back then you didn't have news feeds
people didn't really post a ton of links
on Twitter or whatever so if you wanted
traffic Google needed to love you and
Google at the time was loving blogs so
everybody was like if you want to get
customers you got a Blog so I started
blogging for all these different
um kind of e-commerce businesses or
affiliate marketing businesses one of
which was dating advice and promoting
David D'Angelo's double your dating and
that was the one that started to take
off and I got within probably six months
I got more traction with that one than
all the others combined and so I was
like ah I'll just like kind of keep
hammering on this one that's how it
started but it was still even it was
like two years of that before it even
occurred to me like maybe I should be an
author how did you decide on dating that
you're going to be writing about that
did it start with dating or you started
writing about other things and then
dating just seemed more natural maybe I
started writing about a bunch of
different stuff the dating stuff
and this is the funny thing about
writing so the dating stuff came easiest
to me because I was a single 23 year old
dude and it was fun to write about my
dates and what were you successful with
the ladies Well define success
why was that easy for you
how
it wasn't easy
um
so the pickup artist thing had been
happening around this time and I'd read
the game and a couple of other books and
I had a bunch of friends who were like
really into that world so we had been
going out a lot and
uh you know going to bars and stuff and
approaching girls and so I had been
doing that for a couple years and I had
gotten like I by that point I was
getting good results like I was hooking
up a bunch and dating a bunch of girls
but it's funny because it never occurred
to me of like oh you could
be one of these guys who's coaching you
could write one of these books like it
never dawned on me for some reason maybe
this just has to do with like the level
of their marketing back then but it it
just seemed like they were in like
another world I later realized once I
met most of them that they were just
normal dudes
with really good marketing the dating
writing the dating stuff came easy and I
think one thing that I've learned
throughout my career is that if there's
a certain subject or topic that flows
naturally out of you as you write it
that tends to be your best content and
so I don't think it was really a
coincidence that
it was the easiest for me to write it
was the most fun for me to write and
it's what got the most traction
when I started putting it out into the
world
and so what was it a program that you
were selling at the time to make a
living writing about dating no well so
when I when I first started out it was
just affiliate like okay you know and
that was for David D'Angelo yeah David D
used to offer 200 commissions on his
ebook how oh is that because of all the
upsells yeah so it was funny we were
talking about this before filming yeah I
found David D'Angelo probably when I was
14 or 15 years old in high school I
think it was on eBaum's World or
something like that and I signed up for
like an email newsletter or something
like that and I get his newsletter every
single day in my email I'd read all of
them his titles were so good he was so
captivating he would basically answer uh
questions that people would send in say
hey David here's my situation this
girl's you know this how do I how do I
get her to like me and he would write
this whole thing and say you know I
recommend you use my technique that you
know you could have in my book yeah and
then I think because I didn't have any
money at the time and I had like a
credit card or anything put in I think I
just downloaded it illegally sure and I
read the whole like double your dating
at 15 years old yeah as we did back then
um yeah he offered 200 commission just
because he had so many audio courses
seminars like hundreds of dollars which
at the time and what was the most
expensive one he offered uh oh it went
up to thousands thousands how could you
offer thousands of dollars of value in
life you could
couldn't but but it's funny because
this is so this is one thing that like
my team and I talk about quite a bit
because at this point I'm like I'm a
dinosaur in this world like I've been
doing this for 15 years the prices of
online content has consistently dropped
over the past two decades back then back
in like 2007 2008 whatever
the concept of an online course was so
novel and and just
nobody had ever seen it before that you
could charge this insane premium because
people are like oh well it's online and
you can access it anytime and you know
it's got 20 videos so of course it's
worth two thousand dollars whereas like
these days
online courses are dime a dozen so
you really really really have to have
massive amounts of value in a big I
guess a lot of credibility to be able to
like even charge a few hundred bucks
these days so I haven't done very much
research into the pickup culture but I
know a lot of people that were very
interested in it back in the day could
you maybe say a few of like the pillars
of pickup Artistry that like people like
to teach or like the the grab the pull
of it sure you know
um so there are different schools of
thought believe it or not
um
I'm not kidding I I could give a [__]
dissertation on this
um there were different schools of
thought so there were there were
basically kind of two categories
one was known as canned game which do
you know what this is yes
I haven't heard of this I like this has
not crossed my mind in probably
probably 15 years yeah that's crazy it's
funny because you would memorize these
lines man oh my God so so the the
philosophy behind canned game was
basically uh
you know you as a guy you have there's
probably two or three life stories that
you have that are better than all the
other stories you probably have two or
three questions or ideas that are better
than all your other ideas and so the the
philosophy was you should just figure
out what those best stories and those
best lines are and then just use them on
every single girl you meet because
that's your best material right which is
like there's a certain logic behind that
the problem is is it kind of turns you
into a robot and it turns your dating
life into like this algorithmic like
okay she said response why deploy story
C2 but then also like
man yeah yeah you're using these
crutches and you come across a girl
that's maybe a little I don't know more
sporadic and she says something that
throws you off and you're like uh uh uh
and you can like yeah so that was the
problem that was the problem with candy
so far are until you come up with a
situation where like I don't have a
story for this right exactly crazy you
know about this
is 10 years old I had the canned game
and it was a few times 15 years old how
were you even because at 15 and high
school using this at 15 or whatever I
will try the best it didn't really work
to try to try to score a date which
failed miserably score a date yeah
you're trying to you're just trying to
get a date that's all it was and I'd
have the canned material but it none of
it worked I mean some of it would get
you so far sure and then and that a lot
of it was over like AOL Instant
Messenger it'd be like you know you know
aiming back and forth and you'd come up
to a line it only got so far okay I can
all right what we're going to do right
now is an exercise okay you're gonna say
a canned story and you're gonna say a
canned story what was your go-to can
store no no I hate it I hate it I hate
it oh you didn't have you didn't have no
no so this this is the first school of
thought I was not part of this school of
thought so this was like
Neil Strauss is the game was kind of
like the main can game thing you know
mystery who was talked about in Neil's
book a lot of the earlier pickup stuff
so I guess like 2004 to 2007 was like
very focused on this
what what guys eventually realized is
exactly what
you just said which is like as soon as
you run out of stories you revert you
know it's like Cinderella turning back
into a pumpkin
I think as soon as you run out of
storage you're like oh yeah I'm back to
being that nerdy dweeb who has no
confidence around girls but before we
get into that you guys actually may not
know this but Graham and I have had so
many different businesses we've tried
over the years and if you've ever
started a business yourself you know it
is so hard to manage so many different
spreadsheets softwares plugins all at
the same time but today's sponsor
netsuite is here to help with netsuite
all you got to do is remember three
numbers thirty six thousand twenty five
and one thirty six thousand because 36
000 companies have upgraded the netsuite
they've also stopped doing things like
typing in manual data entry which is
prone for errors and sifting through
scattered information 25 because
netsuite has spent 25 years helping
businesses drive down their costs and
one because netsuite is an all-in-one
solution that allows you to manage all
of your kpis or key performance
indicators with one efficient system
netsuite will also help you reduce the
mistakes for manual data entry and guys
trust me there are always mistakes in
manual data entry and prevent the busy
work from scaling with your business get
a full picture of your business and make
better decisions faster and you can
start by downloading netsuite's popular
kpis checklist for absolutely free at
netsuite.com iced again that's
netsuite.com ice to get your own kpis
checklist for free netsuite.com iced or
the link Down Below in the description
and now with that said let's get back to
the back of the podcast there was a
second school of thought that started to
emerge which was known as natural game
which is ridiculous because it's it's
just being a human being but uh the idea
behind natural game was like okay it's
not about learning lines or uh stories
or whatever
it's about developing the skill set
right
developing social confidence developing
social awareness developing a sense of
humor these these things can be
practiced right like you can you can go
take an improv comedy class and become a
funnier person you can join Toastmasters
and develop more confidence speaking and
better body language and all these
things so the idea was like work on the
the fundamental skills and principles
within yourself and then that will just
kind of naturally translate into greater
success dating which is fundamentally
true so I was a natural game guy like I
I had probably a similar experience to
Grant uh and a lot of people which is I
read the game I was like oh my God I
can't believe this works I went to a bar
tried a bunch of lines and the girls
just kind of looked at me like I had
four heads and I was like you know I
think I did better when I was just
normal so I like went back to normal and
then just
started working from there I was like
why don't we start at normal because I'm
already good at some things and then
just work at the things I'm not good at
right uh which is just logical so I fell
in the the natural game Camp which a lot
of my focus and and as I so I I built
the blog I developed an audience and
then originally I promoted people like
David D'Angelo but then people started
wanting me like specifically to give
them advice right so they're like hey
Mark I've been reading you for a year I
really like your take on things
um here's my situation with this girl
I'm seeing what do you think and
the first dollars I made was charging
money for that kind of thing like you
know hey for 100 bucks I'll hop on the
phone with you for an hour
like talk me through it I'll give you
I'll give you my two cents and
eventually
you know my focus generally became
mostly like what I started to realize
once I started working with a lot of
different men what I started to realize
is that you don't even have like yeah
it's good to be funny that's great you
don't have to be funny to get a
girlfriend or get a date right like you
it's good to have social confidence or
be clever or be really charismatic but
like you don't have to be charismatic to
get a date ultimately what it comes down
to is a certain amount of confidence in
who you are an ability to deal with
rejection or the possibility of
rejection and simply being intelligent
about which women you approach and which
women you ask out and so that became
most of my focus and my content was very
psychologically driven it was like
forget all like
definitely forget the pickup lines let's
even mostly forget the skills and the
the principles and stuff like let's just
focus on you your ability to deal with
your own fear your own sense of
rejection
your own identity
if you get those things straight then
all this other like
everything else will kind of fix itself
uh and that's kind of what I became
known for yo in simple pickup was making
their first videos 2010 2011 YouTube I
learned it really doesn't matter at all
what you say it's just how you say it
yeah that's it I love their videos when
they go up and Mumble some random stuff
can I get your number and they'd be like
sure sure yeah that's fine I'm curious
as a man in the dating pool right now
the hardest part and I'm probably
speaking for a lot of the audience as
well is the fear of rejection right for
sure how did you overcome that fear of
rejection or were you still scared of it
but you were just managing it you know
what and I by the way when it comes to
rejection I think it's more so
embarrassment that that was what it was
for me is just getting embarrassed yeah
without the rejection itself it's like
am I gonna look like an idiot yeah
I think so there's kind of two two takes
one is a certain percentage of it is
just simply desensitization like
the way you realize rejection doesn't
matter is you get rejected enough times
and you're like oh this doesn't matter
so that's part of it that's that's the
answer nobody likes hearing but it's the
truth but another huge part of it and I
talk about this so I I did end up
writing a dating book called models to
track women through honesty and this was
a huge chunk of that book which is most
men who particularly men who struggle
with dating they approach dating as as
though it's a performance right like
okay you got this hot girl to go out
with you now you got to say the right
things you got to do the right things
you got to make her laugh at the right
jokes and if you do that then you get to
win you get to kiss her or hook up with
her or whatever and like it's it's like
they approach it like they're
approaching a level in a video game you
know it's like ah clear all the
obstacles and then you know you you win
the princess at the end and that's a
terrible if you actually look at how
human interaction works that's a
terrible way to approach
any relationship in life like the idea
that you need to perform to make
somebody else like you it's it's going
to even if you succeed you're going to
be dissatisfied with that success
because it's not your actual self that
they're liking it's the performance that
they're liking
so a much healthier way of looking at
dating is that
here's who I am here are the things that
I care about that are important to me
here's the lifestyle that I want for
myself understanding that a vast
majority of the women in the world are
not going to be compatible with those
values in that lifestyle that you want
for yourself but also understanding that
a small percentage of women are going to
be highly compatible with those values
and that lifestyle that you want for
yourself and so your goal therefore is
not to make every woman like you it's to
find that small percentage of women who
are highly compatible with you as
quickly and efficiently as possible and
so once you like really integrate that
into your head rejection no longer
becomes a Bad Thing rejection is simply
part of that process of finding
the compatible women so it's it's women
are actually doing you a favor if they
reject you especially if they reject you
quickly because they are saving you all
of the time and energy that would have
been wasted on a woman who is not
compatible who's not going to make you
happy again you can't just like read
that and overnight feel it but over
enough time you can reach that point
where you do feel that way and so it it
you really not only do you stop caring
but you're actually like completely
comfortable with it I got to the point
where
I would approach a woman at a party or a
bar or whatever talk to her for five
minutes and if she was not
enthusiastically into me I would say
nice to meet you have a nice night and I
would like move on but what if she was
extremely attractive
10 minutes
well then I got this story that I
practice Yeah
yeah yeah but how do you differentiate
between being okay with rejection but
also working on yourself to the point
where maybe you're just not presenting
yourself in the right way like this
person could be a great match sure but
if you don't convey yourself in a
confident way then you're just shooting
yourself on the foot right from the very
beginning it is true
it is true and so that's the argument to
work on yourself primarily you know to
develop social skills and humor and all
those things like those are very
valuable things and by the way not just
valuable and dating valuable and
everything valuable in business valuable
with your family your social
relationships so those are just very
very important skills to have regardless
but the answer to that question and also
the answer to yours is
guys get so caught up especially like if
you're in a room and there's a super hot
girl in front of you and you get the
chance to talk to her
there's something that happens to men's
Brains they start acting like every
other woman on earth died and this is
like the last chance they're ever gonna
have to procreate and it's like dude
there are [__] four billion women on
this planet hundreds of millions of
highly attractive women just in
you know this continent there's there's
no scarcity in terms of opportunities
chances whatever like you're gonna meet
another woman at some point you're gonna
meet another hot woman you're gonna meet
another woman that you Vibe and gel with
the other thing that that it's important
having this perspective for too is that
it's very real in dating that you meet
the right person at the wrong time
like you can meet somebody who's extreme
you're extremely compatible with but but
they're moving across the country in two
weeks or they just got out of a
relationship and you just got into a
relationship like there's there's a lot
of stuff that happens that's completely
outside of your control that if you just
met two weeks prior or uh a year prior
you would probably have a great
relationship and it would change both
your lives but you didn't so you just
kind of learn to let those go as well
like as they say there's always more
fish in the sea which
but before we get into that if you guys
are looking to create high quality
content just like us at a very low cost
unfortunately unlike us we strongly
recommend you guys try out our sponsor
stream yard for those unaware stream
yard is a live streaming platform that
allows you to create really high quality
content with just the click of a button
all you need is a camera and an internet
connection and from there you can stream
content directly from your browser this
is also a platform that we personally
been using now for years and we've been
incredibly happy with them and they've
worked flawlessly they have so many
features like a multi-stream function
where you're allowed to stream on
multiple different websites all at the
same time they also have a whole bunch
of various analytics tools so you can
help measure the success of every single
one of your live streams and compare
that across platforms to see where
you're growing the most and guys even
with all those features we just shared
they're still completely free there is
literally no downside to trying them out
you won't lose any money we strongly
recommend you guys try it with a link
Down Below in the show description and
like I mentioned earlier this is
something that we've been using for
years now we've been so happy with it
the link is down below in the
description and they're a huge supporter
of the podcast so if you want to support
us support them link is down below and
now with that said let's get back to the
episode do you feel like this is
something that every guy should learn
when I hear pick up for me it means more
so working on yourself
and it was the confidence that I gained
from being able to go up and talk to
somebody that helped me so much in sales
is just being able to have that
understanding that like no matter who it
is I can go up and talk to them and
it'll be okay yeah I would differentiate
between say pickup
and just developing very useful life
skills because like
the line between those two things is
very blurry in a lot of cases for a lot
of people like I had a lot of clients
back in the day
really their only issue was what you
just said they just needed they had some
social anxiety they did they were a
little bit unconfident or insecure
around strangers that's really all they
had to get over and it just so happened
that being single and hiring a dating
coach was the way they got over it but
you know you probably could have hired a
business coach gone the networking
events like there are a lot of ways to
attack these issues I would say some of
the fundamental skills that every man
should learn social skills for sure like
you should absolutely focus and work on
your social skills you should absolutely
focus and and work on
um your your sense of confidence sense
of identity and that goes for any single
person like it's any any single person
who does that man or woman it's going to
make your dating life easier but I mean
there are plenty of people who just
marry their high school sweetheart and
like never think about dating a day in
their life and that's cool too so
um you know every everybody's mileage
varies a little bit do you think social
media is making taking social competence
better or worse I think it's a bit of a
mixed bag
I think what I have observed
particularly among like say Jen's ears
is social media it increases their
exposure
to say social expression
like exponentially over say what we were
exposed to when we were young and so
they seem
I find that young people today are
extremely Adept of like noticing
catching memes ideas
common threads that are showing up in
different places like they seem
extremely Nimble and like managing that
and like noticing that
I think what
where they so I I would say they're
maybe ahead of the curve in a certain
sense of maybe just social awareness
I think where they might be behind the
curve
is
a certain amount of uh
I don't want to say emotional maturity
but like there's a certain amount of
emotional development that can only
happen face to face it can only happen
when you are out with a group of friends
and somebody says something that hurts
you or when you're in awkward social
situations where you have to be the
person who walks up and talks to a group
of strangers and I think the more the
more people rely on social media and
online platforms for for their
socialization the less they are forced
to be put in those situations and
develop those emotional skills and so
what I notice is just people being a
little bit behind the curve in terms of
their
social emotional development yeah I
would say what I've noticed being a gen
Zer is a lot of people they're able to
understand where a lot of people are
coming from and like you said like
reading and navigating social situations
they're pretty good at yeah there's not
a lot of depth yeah to them you know
what I mean so they can go mile wide but
not really a mile deep on anything that
Rings true it's funny I've I've just
recently hired a couple of gen's ears
and I've noticed that like they are so
[__] aware of everything and like
really a two months in conversation is
like really attune the stuff how so I'm
so curious uh
I don't know exposure yeah I really
think it's just exposure like you get to
see so many different people
personalities and points of view points
of view on social media and it's just
constantly seeing it and so you're aware
of it and you kind of know how to like
act and react but you don't know the
depths of like where they're coming from
because it's not like you know in-person
conversation I can see you and I I see
you know your point of view but also
we're gonna go in depth about it yeah
but on social media it's kind of just
like oh this guy you know he's like one
of those funny like Fedora wearing
trenchco guys that like you know you
give us an example like I I have a
problem understanding like the depth
aspect of things well I so I have found
you know when I've talked to Jen's ears
I've asked questions which I think
when I was in my 20s would have promoted
like just very thoughtful conversation
like I've point blank asked some gen's
ears like what are your long-term goals
for yourself and they kind of stutter
around and really get kind of
uncomfortable and
kind of give like a non-answer and I'm
like wow that's really interesting
especially because
ninety percent of the Gins ears I'm
exposed to are super [__] smart and
like really Savvy when it comes to like
culture and
what's going on in the world but then
it's like you ask a personal question
and it's just like they're kind of like
stumbling around but you think if you
asked a millennial who was the same age
back then the same question they would
give a better answer I used to sit
around with my friends in my 20s and we
would like sit there and dream of like
what we were gonna do in 10 years and
what we were going to do in 20 years but
that's only because you only knew of a
certain like a selection of things that
were possible whereas now with social
media you're like aware of like okay I
could be a plumber in Nebraska or I
could be you know
multi-billion dollar Media Company
manager it's like you know it there's
like this weird
um relationship between like as
awareness expands
the the in the possibilities expand the
harder it is to narrow your focus and I
think that's where the depth comes in
because depth
to have depth you have to kind of pick
up a lot of land to die on like you have
to be like this is who I am and this is
the thing I care about and this is the
thing I'm gonna defend and The Wider the
options the harder it is to choose that
spot of like yeah this is my identity so
do you think there are too many options
right now across everything absolutely I
think that is
arguably the the largest unspoken
psychological Hazard of today's day and
age and I've I've mentioned that
um
in each of my books particularly the end
of that book like it's there's this
concept of paradox of choice which you
know the more options you're given the
more optionality you're given the the
least the less satisfied you are with
whatever you choose ultimately
and you especially learn this once you
start getting older like you have to
[__] choose something like you can't
when you're young it's easy to kind of
sit around and dream about being like a
world-class expert at five different
things but like once you actually start
working on stuff and you realize how the
insane amount of effort and energy it
takes to get good at just [__] one
thing
you realize like oh [__] like I really
only get like two or three things in my
entire life that I get to dedicate
myself to and so I need to be like very
conscious about what those things are
and so yeah to your point if you've
grown up with literally a million
options at all times how do you pick
those two or three things see as a
millennial I or sorry not as Milan as a
gen Zer I hate the idea that I restrict
my options yeah you know what I mean I
can only choose between some subset of
of choices
I feel like it's more so the
distractions like you pick an option and
you are aware of all the other options
but it's all these distractions like
these ads and like you know you could be
a drop shipper you could be this you
could be that which distract you
although it is another option that
you're kind of aware of do you think
that it's possible to separate options
from distractions and you're aware of
all the options I think distraction is
is another I think I see them as two two
issues
around the same thing right so it's like
even if you have chosen
you know I'm gonna be a [__] great
world-class podcaster
always 10 other things going on at all
times in your life so it's like how do
you say no to all those things how do
you turn all those things off it's it's
it's another complication added on top
of the initial complication how do you
know what to pick I would say it's a
combination of
finding what you're naturally good at
finding what you enjoy quite a bit and
finding
what making sure it's compatible with a
wider lifestyle that you want to have
right so it's it's
maybe you like I enjoy science a lot I
enjoy reading research papers I would
[__] hate it in Academia like I would
be so miserable and so for me it just I
realized years ago that that should
probably be off the table
um
so yeah I think it's a combo of what
you're good at what you consistently
enjoy
and what is
compatible with the rest of your
lifestyle and I guess you part of that
too is you know getting paid for
something yeah I think you really said
it best in a prior podcast I really
liked when you said that you know what
you're really good at when it comes easy
to you yeah when other people ask you
how were you able to do that and you
just say well no it was easy I just I
just did it and I think for me if
personal finance is something that like
I've been obsessed with and even before
making YouTube videos I was on Reddit
talking about personal finance writing
these long like you know analysis is on
random things and I posted on Reddit
that people would like it yeah it's
basically like what feels like play to
you that feels like Worth to other
people and I realized like I learned
this in music school because
music schools is so insanely competitive
for obvious reasons and I remember I was
slowly
like everybody kind of gets weeded out
like 90 of the people in music school
get weeded out and I was I made it
through the first two semesters I was
coming to the end of the second semester
and I could feel like my time was coming
and so I was practicing and and studying
super hard like six eight hours a day
and I remember I went into one of my
private lessons with my my guitar
teacher
and I played a piece that I've been
practicing all week like my my fingers
were sore I was starting to get
tendonitis all this stuff and I started
playing it and I got 15 seconds in and
he like put his hand on my guitar and he
was like stop
you're not practicing enough
and I was like all right dude if this
isn't enough
like [__] all this I'm out of here this
reminded me you know in high school I
really wanted to be a drummer I was in a
band and I remember the moment that I
realized I couldn't do this as a career
I played a show at the Roxy and there
was a band that played after us and I
thought we crushed it it just banned
after us the drummer was insane I bet
the drama was probably late 20s early
30s and this was like Danny Carey sort
of style that to me was like I'll never
get that good like this guy was amazing
like naturally gifted and afterwards
we're talking to the guy and we're
talking to the band and you know
congratulations hey great set you know
just you know being fans and the guy
lived in a van on Sunset Boulevard as
the drummer yeah and purely because the
band wasn't making any money yeah he was
practicing full time uh the rent that he
would have paid goes to a studio that he
splits so he could play the drums and
I'm like this if this guy can't make it
like what does that leave me and this
guy's so much better Dude music is one
of the most ruthless markets maybe the
most ruthless Market in the world I I
it's I can't tell you how many like I
still watch a lot of amazing musicians
on YouTube just for fun I can't tell you
how many
18 year old kids that I watch on YouTube
who can play circles around what I could
ever like I could play at my Peak and I
just look at I'm like I'm so glad I quit
music oh my God but to finish that story
really quick I remember I I got
desperate so there was one guy in my
program who was just clearly better than
everybody else like he was the one guy
everybody was like that guy's gonna make
it and so I went I cornered him in the
cafeteria the next day and I was like
dude I'm like I'm having a crisis here
and he's like oh yeah what's going on
I'm like kind of like laid it all out
I'm like I'm doing this I'm practicing
this and I'm trying this and my teacher
said I'm just not practicing enough I
started asking him questions I'm like
how much do you practice man and he was
like I don't know
it's like what do you mean you know now
and he's like I don't I haven't really
thought about it uh I was like okay well
like how how do you approach a new piece
like what's your process
you know how much time do you spend on
each part what's the warm-up and he was
like
I don't know like I don't I I don't know
I just kind of like sit down and figure
it out and like he couldn't explain to
me what he was doing
and I was like okay if you would guess
how many hours a day are you like
physically playing your instrument
and he was like I don't know like eight
or twelve but I've never really sat down
and counted that's really that's an
interesting question I like it blew my
[__] mind that this guy was just
naturally
unconsciously doing all of the behaviors
that were required to be a top level
musician
um he did end up making it and I
remember that conversation I was like
okay I'm out of here like yeah I had one
friend who made it as a bass player and
it was his entire life but he loved it
like he would be watching TV practicing
fretting yeah and he would listen to a
click track just normally yeah that
would be his background instead of
listening to music I wanted to click
track yeah and at different you know
bpms and that was it and he would just
internalize it and you give him you say
play 90 BPM in this he'll just do it
yeah it was so instinctual for him we
all have a natural competitive Advantage
somewhere our personalities are
different our interests are different
our proclivities are different like
there's something in each of Our Lives
that we
naturally do well
that most people don't or it takes a lot
of effort for most people and the tricky
thing about it is that the things that
we naturally do well they're so natural
to us that we don't realize that we do
it well like I never it never occurred
to me I was a good writer I just I would
get on forums I would get on music
forums and I would like start arguing
with a guy about like which band is
better and I would write like my idea of
a fun Friday night was writing like a
10-page dissertation on why this Tool
album is better than this Tool album or
whatever that's like what I did for fun
and it never occurred to me
that that was writing and that I was
good at it and
I think people make that mistake a lot
that it is because it is so
unconsciously natural to them
they don't realize they've gotten so
good at it and that that's actually
their huge competitive Advantage yeah at
what point did you decide to exit the
dating segment and how much can you
share how much money you made throughout
that process not not that much
really I was imagining yeah I was
listening to a diary of CEO and I was
like yeah it's 100 it's a thousand
dollars and I thought like oh yeah you
just retire from that like that that
industry was shrinking by the time I
left and I could see that it was
it was a sinking ship
um
I started coaching in 08
I was making up full-time income in 09
full-time being like 50k a year or
something I left in 2012.
coach my last client in 2012. I wrote my
my dating book in 2011 that was kind of
like my mic drop moment of like
[__] all you toxic [__] like
here's a healthy
version of of men's dating advice and
then I left in 2012. I think by the time
I left in 2012 I was pushing up close to
100K a year and that was Mo but that was
mostly through online courses
um through the blog I thought it would
be way more I was kind of imagining like
three to five hundred right I don't know
I mean these guys made it seem like
they're making so maybe they are but
like you know it's funny I was never
when I was in that industry I was never
a big
player in the industry I was kind of
like a
B level or c-level guy
um
it was after I left that my stuff blew
up in that industry so like my dating
book became the top men's dating book on
Amazon for like eight I think it it
might still be the top men's dating book
on Amazon how do people find it just go
on Amazon it's right there yeah uh
and I still like I still get royalties
from that today
um
so
yeah it was weird when I was there I was
kind of just this marginal guy who
kept trying to like [__] everybody
else's thing up because I was like no no
no that's that's toxic don't do that do
this instead and
um I was I was very contrarian but then
once I left and I kind of pivoted just
the self-help in general I think a lot
of people
became more aware of me and then things
took off in that industry so when did
the idea for the subtle art come to
fruition so the book itself I started
writing in 2014. so I pivoted I pivoted
away from dating the self-help in 2012.
and then in 20 2012 2013 my blog just
blew up like traffic
probably five or ten next the reason I
did that is because in 2012 I realized
that it's actually very surprising I
really by by the end of 2012 I I had
actually built up a
a sizable audience of female readers
and I kept getting emails from women
saying like I love your blog I love your
articles is this true for women too each
time I would sit there and think about
it I'm like yeah it actually is kind of
true for women too
and that happened enough times that I'm
like why am I writing for men I should
just write for everybody so I rebranded
switched to to just kind of generic
self-help
audience blew up 20 2013 and uh that's
when I was like okay I need the right
like a real book and I I initially I
thought I was going to self-publish it
like my dating book
um but then the odd by 2015 the audience
had gotten so big that Publishers and
agents and stuff had come knocking
um as far the title itself that was an
article in 2015 by then I had finished
most of the first draft of the book but
that article hit so hard like I'd had a
bunch of stuff go viral but that one
just
was like so insanely viral that
um my agent was like
you should you should make that the
title of the book and uh you know make
that chapter one I was like that's not a
bad idea and that no that that you wrote
back then yeah what did you define as
viral how did you know does it show
views is it by comments is it by you
know people responding it's it's funny
back then
um you used to be so Facebook and
Twitter used to show you how many times
uh things got shared like you people
would post so like at the top of an
article You Could See this has been
shared on Facebook two thousand times
and it's been shared on Twitter a
thousand times
they stopped doing that years ago but um
you would see I mean I kind of knew like
a standard article I would write would
get I don't know three to five thousand
shares just like from my core audience
um
and then if things kind of hit ten
thousand twenty thousand whatever you
knew something was kind of popping off
and so I had a number that I had a
number of articles that ended up with 50
000 shares or a hundred thousand shares
on Facebook each of those shares is
probably reaching anywhere from a few
dozen to a few thousand people and then
subtle art hit over a million shares uh
across social platforms and so that
article alone did
I mean it's funny and these days with
YouTube numbers it seems scant but
um that article alone I think that eight
million page views in the first couple
months which back then I think the New
York Times got 30 million page views
like the entire website yeah so
um so yeah that's like massive how did
you come up with the idea the big
contextual piece of information here
that matters a lot is that Facebook
released their news feed in 2011.
Facebook realized pretty quickly that
they wanted to compete they wanted they
wanted to be everybody's homepage like
they didn't want you to go to the New
York Times and like see what articles
they had posted they wanted you to just
get on Facebook
and click on links through Facebook they
started juicing any sort of like
published content on other websites they
started juicing their algorithm to like
promote that because they just wanted
everybody they wanted Facebook to be the
home page of everybody like that's the
first thing you look at in the morning
so if you could create an article
that went viral on Facebook you would
just get this insane insane amounts of
traffic so I figured this out pretty
early like definitely earlier than most
people very similar to what people do
with YouTube these days I also because I
had studied copywriting in previous
years I understood that the two most
important things when you post something
on Facebook or any social media is going
to be the title and then the image that
pops up so if you have a great image and
a great title A lot of people are going
to pop up uh click on it and then if
it's a great article they're gonna share
it and and that share is going to get a
bunch of clicks and then it's just gonna
you know start the start the flywheel so
I spent a lot of time focusing
that's when I actually started again
doing what YouTubers do now which is uh
title first so come up with the title
then create the article what most people
did back then is they would think of the
article they wanted to write write the
article and then be like oh I should put
a title on it
um I realized that the title
basically controls your distribution so
pick the best title possible then write
an article that delivers value based on
that title so I started doing that had a
few quick viral hits I'd say between
2013 and 2012 and 2015 I probably had
like
10 different articles that just
blew up so I went from my dating blog I
think
when I pivoted over my dating blog
probably had 50k to 100K monthly readers
um by 2015 I had like two and a half
million monthly readers wow
um so yeah it like I guess that's a 25x
what were some of the biggest self-help
points that you wanted to get across or
that really did well that people
resonated with so I grew up consuming a
lot of self-help content and when I was
a kid when I was young it was all the
Oprah stuff so it was like the secret
and Power of Now and manifesting and
like
power of positive thinking it was all
very like touchy feely believe in
yourself
you know you're going to be great
whatever and being a millennial like
Millennials were were kind of known for
just being
disaffected and
cynical of everything and I read all
that stuff as a teenager and by like my
mid-20s
I was a little bit bitter about it I was
like this kind of feels like [__]
like it makes you feel good for a little
while but it doesn't actually
change you doesn't actually like create
any behavioral change
around the same time there's a bunch of
new like positive psychology it just
started up in the 2000s and so we were
starting to get the first research like
first actual credible research on like
things like happiness
what improves well-being what may you
know how people how people emotions
react to certain experiences and so I
started diving into that content and it
turned out that like a lot of the actual
academic research on happiness and
emotions completely contradicts like the
classic self-help stuff thinking
positive all the time doesn't always
necessarily help you feeling good about
yourself isn't necessarily always a good
thing so I basically started taking a
lot of that academically rooted
information
and then
zeroing in on that contradiction of like
traditional self-help right so I would
take
you know a piece of research and then
I'd create an article called uh this is
why you shouldn't try to be happy or
like stop trying to be happy which back
then that was super controversial take
in the self-help space and so people
would click on it they're like what stop
trying to be happy like they click on it
and then they start reading it and it's
actually like no it's like rooted in a
lot of like very logical arguments of
how this sabotages you and so that was
that was basically kind of the initial
Mark Manson piece of content like that
was what I became known for these days
you see that [__] everywhere in my
industry like these days
that that basically is the industry to a
great extent but back then it I I think
I was
probably the only person doing it or the
first person doing it so it's like I
captured a lot of that momentum do you
think any of like the OG self-help books
have any value because for me I read The
Power of Now yeah and I thought that was
like one of the best books I've ever
read yeah and I've read a lot of like
self-help books sure none have made the
impact on me that that book has so
here's the funny thing about like
classic self-help books
it's
every single one of them has a nugget of
truth right so Power of Now
yeah developing the ability to be
present is extremely important
is that the only thing you need to know
how to do no it's not and in fact you
need to know how to think about the
future and also worry about the past
because those things are useful but you
don't want to only think about the
future or worry about the past because
then you're just going to be this like
neurotic person right so
there's like
most of my criticism for classic
self-help isn't that it's wrong per se
it's just that it's it's not the full
picture like it's life's complicated and
and in fact a lot of the things that are
good for us are unpleasant and I think
the function of most self-help
throughout its history has been just
make people feel good like here's the
thing that's going to make you feel
better and
in a lot of cases that's helpful but in
some cases it's not
but the to give a few examples I'm a
huge fan there's a classic book called
The Road Less Traveled huge fan of that
book uh him Scott Peck I like The Four
Agreements a lot like it's got all this
like shamanic Universe blah blah blah
which I'm not really into but like in
terms of just four simple Concepts that
you can read that book in an hour and
those four simple
principles uh that it gives like will
probably make everybody's life
slightly better like that's just that's
a good book so I I trash the industry a
lot but it's you don't want to throw the
baby out with the bath water like it's
as with most things it's complicated I
feel like with the Power of Now the part
that I didn't necessarily like was like
the whole reframing of your entire mind
and your behavior and your personality
and your character yes the way that you
see life I don't think that that's very
productive because nobody's actually
going to do that but if you do use the
tool of presence just like I said as a
tool sure then it's great I think you
make a really good distinction I think
if you approach these things as tools
like another great example is the secret
right from a purely scientific point of
view the secrets just complete and utter
[__] but the experience of
manifesting
like if you look at like perceptual
biases and
um confirmation bias and how you can
leverage confirmation bias in your favor
like that's a real thing like if you
focus on a certain goal or idea that you
have you will start noticing things that
are opportunities to move towards that
goal or opportunity so that is a real
thing it's just all the kind of the
fluff and the secret of the The Law of
Attraction like it's a universal law
like the law of graph no it's not it's
just like
human brains are weird we tend to pry we
prioritize what we perceive based on
certain heuristics here's one heuristic
that you can take advantage of now do
you have to explain that all in a book
no but just like don't don't show it as
gospel yeah that's the thing I don't
like yes where it's like this is the
only truth and everything else is wrong
yes because I see that yeah but I feel
like you have to be like that if you're
writing a book about something you have
to be pretty like you know divisive in
terms of that you can't be like well
it's sometimes true but sometimes it's
also not but you know this case could be
true for this person but sometimes it's
more like stumbling on happiness and I
know that you like it I love that book
because it's not necessarily like it's
like hey you know uh one size is not fit
all yeah uh which I really appreciate it
it's not like just like this is the
gospel of how you live a good one what
about you mentioned reframing your mind
yes what do you mean by that like okay
so like completely ignoring certain
things that are 100 True like the fact
that the past yes it kind of will Define
innocence who you are happens to all and
acting just as though that does not
exist which is kind of what the power of
now it's not saying it doesn't exist but
it's saying like you should not
necessarily ignore that but like
almost almost act as though it doesn't
exist I'm not using the right you know
verbage but that's kind of what he's
saying and I don't think that that's a
very productive way because you're
ignoring something that is 100 true and
it's also okay Andrew Tate says he only
has a set of beliefs that
serve him yeah even if he's ignoring
things that are biologically true so he
says he does not believe in depression
now I know that that may come off as
silly but he does not believe in it
because to not believe in it does not
allow him to be depressed is his logic
and if that's not true for everybody but
if it just does so happen to be true for
him right if it works for you I don't
believe in taxes they just don't exist
right well because it doesn't serve me
but that belief wouldn't be serving you
right because then you'd be back on your
taxes but it doesn't believe something
and if it works for him what do you
think about ignoring certain things that
are 100 True to carve out a belief
system that only serves you even if
you're living Blissful ignorance of
certain things it [__] you up you think
so it absolutely it will maybe it wins
for a month maybe it wins for a year
eventually it will come and bite you in
the ass because
any part of reality that you ignore you
are
preventing yourself from from building
the tool sets and in the ideas necessary
to handle that aspect of reality so
if God forbid Andrew Tate ever becomes
depressed or somebody very close to him
in his life becomes depressed he's going
to be completely ill-equipped to deal
with that situation and
very much like not believing in taxes as
soon as the IRS shows up Suddenly It's
not in my interest anymore right so how
do you first of all you get this fuzzy
definition of like what is actually in
your interest on what time scale like
okay it makes you feel better today
that's great but what about a year from
now what about 20 years from now uh
but then second it's just I and again
this is like backed up by the research
like it's I fundamentally believe that
you should
we should make every effort possible to
see reality as it is
and and not turn away from yeah but then
but what's the difference between that
and focusing on things that benefit you
like let's say a situation happens uh
you know and it's a bad thing but you
could find a positive and focus on that
or say maybe I don't know the real
reason that this happened but how could
I benefit from it happening and learn
from that as long as you're not denying
the bad thing that happened right so
like a bad example of the or so an
example of like doing this in an
unhealthy way is like let's say my wife
divorces me
and all my friends come over and they're
like oh my god dude I'm so sorry this is
terrible and I'm like no you know what
it's great because like now I can
I can travel whenever I want and go out
whenever I want and hey I get the date
again this is going to be amazing
obviously I'm just like [__] deluding
myself now maybe I do after the divorce
start traveling again dating again
trying a bunch of new things
and a lot of these things do improve my
life and I do become a better person and
I can look back later and say you know
the divorce sucked but all these good
things happened as a result so I don't
regret it it was a learning experience
whatever like that that latter
interpretation is the healthy
interpretation like bad things can lead
to good outcomes
just pretending the bad thing never
happened and everything's good all the
time that's just delusion and so you're
gonna again and what we find is that
people who don't admit that a bad thing
is a bad thing
they you're basically you know your your
brain is like your body you're like your
muscles if you don't use it you lose it
so if you're not using the muscles in
your mind that deal with negative
emotion you're just gonna remove your
ability to handle negative emotion when
it does happen so it's like at some
point something absolutely horrible and
tragic is going to happen and I'm going
to be completely ill-equipped to deal
with that reality when it does whereas
if I'm consistently practicing noticing
negative emotions and negative things
that happen in my life and coming to
terms with them and being realistic
about them and understanding that
you know life is complicated there can
be good externalities and bad
externalities to to good and bad events
when the next bad event happens I'm
going to become like very very stable
and flexible in handling it and how do
people get to that point how do they
start it is as simple and difficult as
simply not turning away from it and
we
trick ourselves and invent all sorts of
methods to turn away from the bad ugly
things in our life but it's it's really
just developing a habit and a skill set
of recognizing
a pile of shit's a pile of [__] you know
depression is depression you can call it
whatever you want but
most people on this planet at some point
in their life fall into a funk where
they feel a lack of motivation they feel
a lack of self-worth they feel a lack of
Direction in their lives
you pick whatever label you want it
exists it happens right and it happens
to everybody at some point if you don't
admit that that's a thing then when it
happens you're going to be completely
ill prepared so it's it's this regular
and constant practice of being like okay
a bad thing happened
it's okay
you know there's good externalities
there are bad externalities to that like
how can we make the best of it and and
this is why like
I don't know I always tell people like
so many people spend so much time and
energy worrying about
um whether something is deserved or not
like oh this bad well he deserved that
or no he didn't deserve that he he
deserves better whatever it's like
doesn't [__] matter all all that
matters is what actions you choose
in reaction to that event like so the
worst [__] thing can happen in the
world the first question you should be
asking yourself is okay what's the best
action I can take
based on this situation if the best
thing
happens in the world your first question
should be what's the best action I
should take based on this this event
it should never change what I loved in
this book as well as the subtle art uh I
think you brought it up in both was that
people conflate responsibility and fault
yeah all of the time which kind of
reminded me of what you just said yeah
when I 100 agree everything that happens
to you in life and every choice that you
make is a hundred percent your
responsibility yes and of course there
will be certain things that occur in
your life that are not your fault
absolutely but at the end of the day if
you get hit by a car and you're lying in
a hospital bed and you're like well it
wasn't my fault it's still your
responsibility to go through physical
therapy to get better to I don't know
reach out to people that can help you
maybe if you're struggling mentally and
what's crazy too is that
I mean so if something bad happens to
you
and it involves another person a lot of
people it's very easy to blame that
other person but but if you end up in a
situation like I don't know like let's
say an earthquake hits California like
the middle of this interview and
kills one of my best friends
that's obviously nobody's fault like
that's just [__] life right and and
it's but still even people will spend so
much time and energy laying awake in bed
trying to figure out well did he deserve
that you know was he a bad person was he
at fault for that was it God was it was
it the universe was it like all these
like we just we keep we spend so much
time spinning up all these stories and
so little time asking ourselves what's
the best thing we can do in this
situation doesn't matter whose fault it
is it doesn't matter why it happened 99
of those stories that you invent for
yourself are gonna be false they're
gonna be made up they're gonna be
inaccurate so what can you do that's
going to be beneficial and on top of
just being productive it's also ethical
because you can get caught in these Echo
chambers of either entitlement yes if
you think that you earn something uh or
it could be victimhood if you think like
you're just lamenting over something
that happened to you or happen to
somebody that you care about yeah yeah
and it's what happens is a lot of these
narratives then prevent us from taking
certain actions right so it's it's if I
convince myself that a certain certain
people were to blame for this horrible
problem in my life uh
that's going to alter my ability to to
take action in my life or take action in
a situation that might involve them why
do you think people overthink everything
so we have this natural proclivity to
spin up these stories around events in
our lives and and there's a there's a
practical you evolutionary purpose to
this right like
researchers have found that this kind of
innate sense of Tit for Tat Justice is
very much inherent in human psychology
right so it's like you punch me on the
arm
it only feels correct that I punch you
on the arm you know if if somebody
steals a hundred dollars from you it
only feels correct that you get the
hundred dollars back like it's like this
equal and opposite sense of
of morality that happens I think for
most of human history this was necessary
to kind of regulate human tribes right
make sure if you steal from him then he
you he gets something back from you Etc
so it makes sense that our mind is
always we're always trying any event
that happens we're we're trying to
create narratives around two things one
is is this a good or bad thing how good
is it how bad is it is it the worst
thing is it the best thing
and then the second thing the second
narrative that we spin up around it is
does the person deserve this are they a
good or bad person did they do a good or
bad thing to deserve the good or bad
thing that happened to them it's just a
very
primitive natural state of response to
any sort of event and I think first of
all
those stories tend to be extremely
flawed they tend to be extremely biased
they don't acknowledge our own imperfect
information I think especially in the
day and age of the internet we are all
learning the hard way how little we know
at any given time about any subject
whatsoever
and
I've just found that so many people that
I talk to or that I've worked with in
the past
have spent Decades of their lives hung
up on these stories of like you know
they grew up in a [__] up
household when they were a kid so they
generated these stories about how
they're a bad person and their parents
punish them because of this and then you
fast forward 20 years and they're in a
relationship and they've had a kid of
their own and it's completely [__] up
their family life because they've held
on to that story for that long and so
they're like we do this in macro ways
and we do it in microwaves and
I think if you look at a lot of the
traditional wisdom whether it's the
stoics Buddhists even Christianity like
it's so much of it is trying to get
people to let go of these stories right
it's like Buddhism tells you everything
is impermanent
uncertainty is the only certainty let go
of everything uh the stoics say you know
like it's don't get attached just to
emotions don't get attached to
narratives uh withhold judgment
Christianity says radical forgiveness
love your love you know if a person
smites you on One Cheek turn the other
cheek it's it's like as humans as
Society has scaled to such a level and
complexity we need these constant
reminders of
don't buy into that story that first
story that pops into your mind after any
event it's probably wrong it's probably
self-serving it's probably extremely
judgmental and it's probably not going
to serve you or anybody else see I tend
to take the approach if anything happens
whether it be good or bad I tend to
think
um how
how will this serve me in the future
what can I learn from this and how can I
benefit from this so if a negative
experience happens I just think first of
all everything happens for a reason is
one of the things that I tend to believe
and that maybe there's a bigger purpose
behind it long term that maybe you're
not aware of now sure but I try to
reframe everything is just how could I
benefit from this where will this serve
me in the future what can I learn from
it and then for a lot of things too it's
just like you you have a lot more
control than I than you think absolutely
and I think so that that classic that
classic cliche that's a cliche for a
reason uh everything happens for a
reason again that's a good example of
something that kind of gets imbued with
this Cosmic significance of like oh the
universe has a plan for your God as a
plan for you I don't necessarily believe
that but I do think everything happens
for a reason but you have to go make
that reason you have to decide okay my
wife left me this is absolutely [__]
horrible
but it happened for a reason and I need
to go find that reason I need to go find
a way to make this a good thing in my
life you said something at the end of
the subtle art it was one of my favorite
chapters I've ever read in my entire
life which was that it's important and
productive to always be contemplating
your own mortality and know that at any
given moment you could die someone that
you love can die and then all can just
end yeah you told a story where you went
to the edge of a cliff yeah and stood
there yeah for a while and you also said
on a podcast that you have like a fetish
for standing
at the edge of very steep Cliffs where a
slight breeze or a little gust of wind
could push you off to your death yeah is
that is this true yeah
yeah it's uh much the consternation of
of my family
um
I've done it less okay lately uh as I've
gotten older and I I try to I'm a little
bit of an adrenaline junkie but
um
yeah there's just a rush that comes I've
got this one of my favorite photos of
myself is me sitting at the edge of the
Grand Canyon on a cliff that's probably
a thousand feet up and uh just looking
out over it and I don't know it's just
it's I feel so alive in those moments
and I
I had a number of people close close to
me die
at a young age and so
it forced me to confront a lot of
I guess it forced me to confront
mortality probably earlier than most
people are forced to confront it
and I found that at a pretty young age
that it's one of the few things that
clarifies what's important to you
because it's and again this kind of
comes back to the point about gen Z and
social media like when you're exposed to
such a breadth of information
and everything is relative to everything
else right so it's it's this thing here
seems important or less important
because this thing seems more important
there there doesn't seem to be any Solid
Ground to judge everything by and I
found that the only thing that seems
absolute and unnegotiable is that you're
going to be dead someday and once you
realize that
then you say okay
Dead one day what are the three things
that I care about and that that starts
this process of clarification of like
okay like separate what matters from all
the noise so in Eckhart tolles and new
earth he says obviously every experience
everything that happens to everything
that you go through is an opportunity
for Spiritual realization and you're
going to have so many opportunities
throughout your life and you can realize
more and more at different ages
um but if you've missed out to be
self-actualized or whatever throughout
your entire life you have one final
window of time right before you die
you're lying on your deathbed and you
think like oh what are the things that
actually matter to me what are my values
you can base it off of that
which I found really interesting I I'm
curious to know how do you contemplate
mortality and your own existence and
knowing that you're just a speck of dust
without becoming a nihilist in a bad way
I feel like like I mean you've talked
about this a lot you call it the
uncomfortable truth sure right the fact
that you are meaningless and there's
you're just nothing right yeah yeah
um how do you not see that and become
like you know it's all for nothing I'm
just gonna sit back play video games
because that gives me those quick
dopamine hits yeah so maybe this is
where Tate actually comes in handy
um
the answer is because that's not useful
uh
there are two ways to look at nihilism
one is nothing matters we're all going
to die so whatever might as well like
do a bunch of coke and blow all your
money or whatever
the other approach is
nothing matters we're all gonna die so
there's no reason to not do
the best things possible for yourself
and others right like we all have a
limited amount of time in existence our
Consciousness has a limited amount of
time in existence so we might as well
try to optimize that time as much as
possible for happiness love and
well-being and there are obviously
behaviors that are better for optimizing
that than others it's kind of this
double-edged sword there's no reason to
do it but there's also no reason to not
do it and this is this is recently it's
funny when I was on tour for this book
because that's largely what this book is
uh uh an audience member came up to me
and he was like he said this is called
uh optimistic nihilism and I was like
what and he's like he's like Google it
it's like there's a small community of
people
and sure enough it's kind of this idea
of optimistic nihilism that yeah if
nothing means anything then you have no
excuse to not get up and [__] do good
things and take care of people and tell
people how you feel about them and
give everything every moment you have so
why aren't more people doing that then
fear avoidance it's the uncomfortable
truth
uncomfortable uncomfortable I think
people are just too comfortable
I think people are getting too
comfortable with
having so many options I think the
Baseline for what we need to live uh is
is almost provided in a sense like you
had mentioned before that you know a
hundred years ago it was like getting
food on the table finding a place to
sleep at night finding a partner like if
you could do a few basic things you're
set it's meaning too it's fulfilling the
purpose yes it was very clear that if
you did these things you would be happy
you'd be content you'd be satisfied with
it but now there's so many different
options so many different distractions
that that you're comfortable so
comfortable in fact that you never even
try because you already got what you
kind of need a lot of modern luxury
is designed to help us avoid
the uncomfortable but important things
we need to think about right like our
death or a loved one's death or
um or some sort of tragedy
that might happen in the future like we
don't like thinking about those things
so we we distract ourselves and and find
ways to avoid them and I think there's a
very strong argument that the
conveniences of modern living make that
avoidance or distraction simpler
um and so it's it's harder for some
people it's going to be more difficult
to come to terms with these questions
you said that when you're no longer like
needing physical needs like shelter food
water just basic things for survival a
lot of the times your purpose and your
meaning will go away so it turns from
like physical struggles to like
existential uh struggles and you also
mention the year after you sold the
subtle art and it like blew up did
extremely well exceeded expectations but
I don't even know how much you had your
own existential crisis and it was one of
the worst years of your life totally I
was super depressed that year which is
weird because I just experienced the
greatest success in my career
right
[Laughter]
I could say to that it's it's hard to
talk that when you get to a certain
point it's like absolutely how do I do
even more than this right I get that but
you also wrote the book which kind of
should have been used as a tool to solve
that existential crisis why do people
yeah know what is good for them but they
don't do it I am so tired of people
coming to me for advice whether it's
Financial not actual Financial advice
but how do I set up a budget and I can
tell them and I tell them exactly how to
do it and they don't do it they know
it's right why do people know they
should break up with their toxic
girlfriend but they don't do it yeah why
do people not do the things they know
they're supposed to do it's hard it's
painful it's uncomfortable they have to
confront and deal with a bunch of
emotions they're not used to confronting
or dealing with which comes back to the
argument of get good at dealing with bad
things like that is that's the muscle to
lean into to practice
um it's like knowing exactly how to lose
20 pounds but not going to the gym and
I definitely I ate a big dose of Humble
Pie after that book came out because
it's like oh yeah you think you're a
smart [__] like here you are
sitting on the couch playing video games
all day like not knowing what to do with
your life
I mean Graham nailed it though like
there's one thing that it it gave me an
appreciation of is that
there's something to be said about
always knowing
always having something better in mind
for the future right it's like okay you
know this project that we did was good
but the next one's gonna be even better
and that works throughout an entire
career or even personal life
until you get a win that's so massive
and so inexplicably
off the charts that you're like okay
there's no way you know and then then
you have to confront the fact of like oh
now everything I do going forward is
going to be less successful than this or
compared to that yes totally so that
that was very hard to deal with and hard
to swallow and you know what's funny
I uh the worst thing about it too is
that you know you just made millions of
dollars and you're depressed and like
obviously everybody in your life thinks
like
you must be so happy like this is the
best thing that's ever happened to you
so you don't feel like you can complain
to anybody like you you don't like I
felt like an idiot talking to anybody
about it
um which made it even worse right
because if you're depressed the number
one thing you should do is go talk to
somebody and uh it wasn't until I
remember I was hanging out with a friend
in New York who was a really successful
startup founder
and had sold his business for nine
figures a couple years prior and he
asked me he was like how you been doing
like how's the book success going and I
was like oh it's been amazing blah blah
this happened this happened he's like no
but really like how how's it been going
I was like honestly man I'm pretty
[__] lost
pretty depressed and he's like yeah I
get that
he's like selling my company
it's like one of like the worst years of
my life like I had no idea what to do
he's like I still don't know what to do
I was like God damn all right well I
think people really like progress like
it's a lot better to go from one to two
to three to four then like one two ten
back to two yeah it's a big change well
also I bet you probably thought that
that was going to be the most amazing
thing ever right like you built it up
and then you actually achieve it and you
feel probably exactly the same as you
did yesterday and you're like oh okay so
that's the problem too is that you you
hit all these dreams that you've had and
you wake up and you
your farts smell just as bad and you're
just as hungover or tired and you're
wife is complaining about dirty dishes
like you're like wow nothing changed
absolutely nothing changed is that where
you came up with a concept oh no no you
got it from Kant about the the pursuing
the
what was it the ends or making every
decision in your life seeing it as the
end yes rather than seeing it as the
means to get to an end never treating a
human being including yourself as a as a
means but only as an end
um that's kant's like kind of Bedrock
principle behind his morality and it was
funny because when I went into this
depression I started reading a lot of
philosophy uh
because I was like well [__] I just like
maxed out every metric of success I've
ever had for myself so and here I am
like not happy so like time to do some
reading figure out what the [__] going
on and uh and I came across that kant's
principle and like that to me that kind
of solved the nihilism for me like it
kind of
that was the puzzle piece that
explained what I what I said a few
minutes ago which is like you know if
nothing means anything
but conscious is limited Consciousness
is limited then it is our moral duty to
improve the quality of that
consciousness
as much as we possibly can
until we die
can I ask how much you made from the
book
um
so it is sold I think 16 million copies
16 to 17
probably a third of those are foreign I
mean you probably get depending it
varies a lot based on format country
um
agent fees stuff like that but generally
per copy I'm making
between a dollar between one and three
dollars probably per book maybe like 150
per book
um so yeah that pre-tax that would be
I'd 25 30 million probably wow yeah what
was the process like of writing that
book How long did it take you and how do
you get in the frame of mind to sit
there and I guess it comes easy for you
structuring it how long do that yeah it
took me about two years to write it
um
you know my dating book
was like 50 blog posts and I kind of
just dumped like brain dumped into it in
a couple months and then I revised it as
I went like I it went through a few
revisions over the next year with help
from readers
so I didn't really write that book like
I kind of wrote it in public with with
the help of my readers but I naively
thought oh writing a book is easy it
just took me a few months so when I
started subtle art I kind of had the
same naive perspective
uh but it ended up taking about two
years the first the first version of it
was pretty terrible I showed it to some
friends they were like there's some good
stuff in here but there's a lot of weird
[__] like just dumb stuff uh so I ended
up cutting half of it
starting over writing a second version
that second version is what got
pitch to The Publisher
um and then I went through a bunch of
rounds with my editor how did you know
what to cut out because I would have the
sense that if you wrote it you might
have the idea that no I wrote it it's
good it's like it's there you don't know
what you're talking about how do you
humble yourself to take outside opinions
and say no you're right I gotta cut half
honestly I feel like that's the real
skill of writing
um
it's knowing like everybody's got ideas
and and most smart people are able to
like write down a bunch of their ideas
it's knowing which ideas are good and
bad that separates like a good writer
from a great writer in my opinion
um
I just I I
will go back and re-read my work and I
will reread it from a few different
perspectives so the first and most
important one is my uh like just my own
like if I get bored reading it
it's gone like if you can't if I can't
entertain myself I'm not gonna entertain
anybody else that's the first cut
um then I'll kind of go back and I'll
put myself in the shoes of say an
average reader
um so back in my dating advice days I'd
imagine myself as kind of like this like
lonely single college kid who like can't
get a date and then I would read it
imagining myself as that person
and if I hit anything that kind of
was confusing or upsetting I would cut
that
um and then one thing I don't do as much
lately is I'll put myself in the shoes
of like a hater or a Critic and I'll
like reread it with that mindset
and same thing I'll cut some things the
other part too is you just show people
like I've got probably five or six
people in my life that I'll show a bunch
of early writing to early drafts
chapters stuff like that and if they
come back like if one person doesn't
like a section I'll kind of
I'll take a look at it but I won't
necessarily cut it if more than one
person doesn't like a section or a point
then it's gone how is having money
changed your perspective on life
[Laughter]
that's a really good question
that could be a whole podcast itself
it's funny it it has changed some things
that I didn't expect it to change and
it's
and then there I guess there are other
things that I kind of expected to change
but it did not my day-to-day life is
basically exactly the same as it was
before being rich which I'm happy about
I think that's a good thing
it has changed my perspective
on
it's given me a much greater
appreciation of
how much perceived status matters
unconsciously to a lot of people like
people
not everybody treats you differently but
a lot of people do
um not only in professional situations
but also social situations and you can
tell that they're treating you
differently
that has been a little bit surprising
and changed my perspective a little bit
never thought I would say this it's
definitely altered my politics a little
bit particularly because you know when
you don't have money it's very easy to
hold a lot of views about
say taxes and spending in government
but once you have money whether you want
to or not you are forced to start
dealing with the government a lot more
you have to interface with them a lot
more you get audited you talk to the IRS
more often you have more accountants you
have lawyers you get sued for things
like
and that having that perspective is I
guess it's it's honestly it's just being
educated now on things like taxes the
legal system regulations
and seen up close and personally how how
the government functions has absolutely
changed my pers it's moved me right word
I guess uh
economically on the political Spectrum
um because it's not impressive the
interactions that you have of all places
why would you be in California quality
of life
quality of life I mean government's not
everything politics isn't everything and
I don't think you should make it
everything
um
I love the beach I love the weather
and and I I do like the people out here
um
what else has changed
I don't know I I do think there's a
natural like when you get a bunch of
money dumped on you
at first you kind of don't know what to
do with it
and then there's just this not very
natural inclination of like well I
should find something to do with it like
it shouldn't just sit there you know
especially back in these days when it
was like this is zero percent interest
savings accounts so it's like I should
do something you know I should go invest
and I should buy property and buy crypto
and take a bunch of trips and and that's
fun for a while but
one of two things starts happening or
two things start happening really is one
is you realize that those things are fun
for like a year or two and then they get
old and then the second thing you notice
is that
um a lot of things that are kind of
cracked up to be like good financial
decisions are not good financial
decisions and so
um yeah now most of my money just sits
in uh
lofi ETFs and does nothing yeah what are
some of the bad financial decisions that
you're talking about
um buying a house that's too big
you'll probably have a lot to say on
this or this will not yeah yeah maybe
maybe you've been down maybe
smiling gearing up for this let's see it
um
yeah we bought a house that was way too
big and it's funny because you don't
think about the downsides right this is
the house during now no no no okay now
the house we're now is [__] great
um imagine you said it's too small yeah
uh
no you kind of
especially living in New York we were my
wife and I we were like so used to
places that were too small that when we
started looking at the places we could
afford we were like oh my God like what
if we got this one and then we'd go see
an even bigger one we're like what about
this one oh my God and
you know we just got
I guess seduced uh because when we
actually moved in we realized hey we
don't we don't have enough stuff we like
literally don't have enough stuff to
fill the house so then you feel
obligated to fill the house
which means buying a bunch of furniture
you don't need
and now you're dealing with a bunch of
contractors and designers and stuff that
you don't really want to be dealing with
so that happened and then the second
thing is is that there's actually kind
of this
you know we don't have kids so it's just
me and her she got an office I got an
office she had a bathroom I had a
bathroom she had like this personal
space I had a library you know we all
had we had rooms for all of our own
things so we never saw each other until
like a year or two went by and we're
like we never see we're like we're both
in the house all the time and we never
see each other and it we realized that
we like didn't like that we like we
started getting nostalgic about our
little 900 square foot
apartment that we lived in before the
house because we were always
basically in the same room together and
and so yeah it was
that house was just like one headache
after another and then of course there's
all the usual headaches that come with
home ownership you know the maintenance
and contractors and taxes and everything
so I was fortunate to get out of that
um to not lose any money on it but
looking back it was just it was a dime
how big was the house uh almost 6 000
square feet okay yeah see I'm in 4 000
square feet now but then again I work
from home we have two offices there and
I'm like I would love another thousand
square feet really like I would love
yeah because the drum set I have is in
the closet like there's no room and then
you need a guest bedroom for when guest
come in and yeah yeah and that takes up
a third of the house right there yeah
yeah we're we're in about we're like 3
800 or something like that it feels
perfect but then it's funny as soon as I
started doing YouTube videos
we were like oh [__] I need to go get a
studio somewhere well that's when you
convert the garage I don't know if you
have a garage or not but yeah yeah then
you do a converted garage move the
studio there yeah you're set yeah
so we're we're happy now but it it it
was too much for sure how did you start
saying no to things because when you
were talking about being in a space
where you're like I don't know how long
this is going to last so I may as well
say yes to every opportunity
um for me I really resonated with that
because for me going into YouTube it's
like I had studied this thing like
before even making a first video I'm
like okay if it goes well I got maybe
five years doing this yeah so I'm like I
would say yes to every podcast sure
every event whatever people could throw
I was posting as much as I could because
I'm like you know if I only have two
years I may as well post nine videos a
week yeah and I would just pump out as
you know everything just because I felt
it was going to go away I think this is
maybe the most important question for
most people's careers
it's also the hardest to answer because
I I think every career you have periods
where you should say yes to everything
like if you're young and starting out
you should say yes everything when you
were starting on YouTube you should be
posting everything you should be making
every video you should be going on every
podcast
it's the same thing I did when I started
eventually you hit an inflection point
where you you get overloaded and
the value you're receiving from each new
thing is not proportional to your time
and energy that you're putting into it
so that's when you have to learn how to
start saying no to stuff
I got kicked back into saying yes to
things when subtle art took off I
started getting opportunities that
realistically I was like
this may never happen again like doing
the Will Smith book right or doing a
Feature Feature movie with Universal
Pictures like
you're probably never going to get get
that phone call again
so you might as well say yes to it
because it might create further
opportunities down the road so I had
another period of saying yes to
everything
um
2017 through 2021 and I don't regret it
but it was absolutely exhausting and
completely burnt me out and so I had to
go back into a process starting maybe a
year ago of okay I need to say no to
most things again
for me the like it's gonna depend
where you are personally in your career
and part like part of it is just
kind of a calculation of like does this
add value
like I could go speak at a conference in
Europe and make 50k right but is that
really adding a whole lot of value to my
career probably not it doesn't scale
and then two it's like I don't need the
50K
and that's probably five days I'm I'm
gone and I'm not working on something
else so the opportunity cost is pretty
significant
so that these days that's a no like just
an immediate no so part of it's the
equation the second part which I think
is the harder part is developing a trust
in yourself to know that
things are going to be good for a while
that like
you don't need these opportunities
because there's going to be more down
the road and that
it took me a while to build that that
confidence both very early in my career
and then again after subtle art because
it's
you start telling yourself these things
of like well maybe this is like my 15
minutes and maybe like this year is it
and so I better say yes to everything
at some point
after a couple years of that in after
the success has been sustained long
enough you have to trust yourself that
it's like okay I've made it this far
I've done this many things successfully
every year has gotten better in the
previous year this is probably going to
continue like
I can say no to stuff I don't need to
have that scarcity mentality right I
guess the third thing which is the the
maybe the hardest and
most complicated
and most personal is I definitely found
it it helped to like I guess hit hit my
number
um
especially leaving New York and coming
here like cost of living I know cost
living is high here but cost living here
is like half of what it is in Manhattan
um the house I bought here is less than
half of the house I had in New York
um so when I got out here and I like sat
down and kind of ran all the numbers and
everything I'm like
I really don't need the work ever again
if I don't want to
and I think once you hit that moment
then it just becomes like okay the only
reason to do something is because I want
to do it it's because I'm excited to do
it it's because it's going to improve my
life in some way
um
and so I've I took I took a long period
of time off last year and and very
intently focused on what am I gonna do
like what what do I enjoy doing what am
I excited to do uh and then you find
those two or three things that like you
get super pumped about and then you just
say no to everything else did that
happen naturally or were you forced to
go and and think about those things I
think it was pretty natural like I Knew
by the end of 21 I knew I was like
extremely burnt out and I was not
enjoying my business anymore and I was
not enjoying the speaking and the
touring and everything
so it coincided with moving here to La
like in that that timing worked out nice
I was originally I told myself I'm gonna
take two months off took two months off
I got to the end of two months I'm like
nope still hate my business still don't
want to talk to anybody so let's do two
more months
and then in the next two two months
you know that's when a lot of the
questions that the real first of all the
realization of the financial
Independence and then a lot of the
questions of like all right dude you're
about to hit 40.
you've made it you can do anything you
want for the rest of your career like
the only question is what do you want
what what is fun what is exciting what
adds value
and
um and so I spent I spent most of those
probably like
month four and five kind of like
figuring that out
dipping my toe in the water of a few
different projects journaling a lot so
this newer sense of like fulfillment
happiness ease I would say like not so
much stress was a product of what you
would have called or you probably still
call it external
um factors yeah whatever because you
compare like the external values versus
the internal values so would you say
that sometimes pursuing some form of
external value or if you achieve an
external value as a product of uh maybe
like going for an internal value that it
still can provide you with like a sense
of calmness and and joy and happiness
I'm glad you brought this up so the
tricky thing with with chasing external
metrics is that you can't really stop
it's
as human beings like we're always going
to like seeing number go up we're always
going to see
like there's not a person on this planet
that if you walked up to them and said
hey how would you like to double your
bank account nobody on the planet is
going to say no like it's just
we're humans we like to see things get
bigger numbers go up we like the
external validation so like that's never
going to go away the important thing is
that you're not basing your life around
those external metrics that you have
some internal metrics
that you're then basing the external
around right so if you're just and this
is what happens with YouTubers a lot
like they get on YouTube
they start building an audience
they get addicted to like number go up
right and so they start making any
content saying anything that just makes
number go up and so they lose themselves
they'd actually they don't really care
about what they're making they don't
actually believe a lot of the things
that they're saying they're just chasing
numbers over and over again and it makes
them miserable like if you ever
sacrifice the internal for the external
you're going to make yourself miserable
what you have to do is you have to
figure out what are the internal metrics
that are going to guide everything
you know whether that's impact
Financial Security taking care of your
family whatever wouldn't that be
external though
Financial Security and impact I would
say Financial Security is is absolutely
internal because
they're I know a lot of millionaires who
feel like they're broke
and I know a lot of people with 10K in
their bank and they're completely secure
and happy so
it's the internal metric is very much
it's
what is the state of mind that I want to
have in my life like what is the state
of mind that I'm going for and
everybody's the way that interacts with
the external world is going to be a
little bit different for everybody some
people are going to feel broke at 10
million some people are going to feel
completely fine at 10 000 right so
but you have to start with that like
okay what is my internal value like what
do I what do I want my state of mind to
be like for me it's it's I enjoy
creating
without Authority above me without
limitation right it's like I I just
enjoy thinking and sharing ideas
and I enjoy scaling those ideas like
that's just fun to me and so then you
have to look at okay so what are what
are the external metrics that align with
those internal metrics that will are
accurate measurements of achieving that
internal measurement so you know
say writing an article that people like
like that's that's a success that's an
external metric that lines up with my
internal metric so the way that I
understood that was that you have these
internal values and they basically act
as guides or Arbiters of certain
decisions that you are going to be
presented with at a future opportunity
right so they're basically making the
decision and taking that burden off of
your future self's shoulders
um and that you should feel fulfillment
that you stay true to that not
necessarily attached and feel
fulfillment from the outcome of those
decisions the internal guides like the
values that you decide for yourself
they become the heuristics of how you
how you move through the world it's like
basically like what are you what are you
going to optimize for are you going to
optimize for clicks are you going to
optimize for impact are you going to
optimize for Creative satisfaction like
those are all those all all three of
those things produce completely
different careers and they can all be
internal values there's an external
representation to them right so if you
opt if you're optimizing for just
attention
that's going to be represented through
views and clicks if you're optimizing
for impact
then that's probably going to be
represented externally through like
emails fan fans reaching out followers
like the thing the the qualitative
things that are said to you like maybe
you have a hundred fans but all 100 of
those people are like you completely
changed my life uh and then if you're
optimizing simply for Creative
satisfaction then you you
probably don't give a [__] you just put
it out and as long as it's beautiful and
you're you feel good looking at it then
you're satisfied but those all create
like and those are all completely valid
ways to build a life and build a career
in the world but they produce completely
different outcomes and I think it's fine
like the mistake that people make is
they just pick an external metric
because they think it's going to make
them look cool in front of their friends
or it's going to get them more dates or
it's gonna ease the anxiety they feel
all the time
and the truth is is that purely external
metrics without any sort of like
internal tethering to a value uh
they just make you feel worse in the
long run how do you know when is enough
dude I don't know
[Laughter]
I
I guess I would say enough is when
pursuing more is is creating more harm
than it is good
um
which I that inflection point absolutely
exists
I think on most most Dimensions most
metrics how did you know it was enough
for you I guess based on your own I feel
like someone would have had to tell you
because I feel like when you are so you
when your judgment is so clouded when
you are in the thick of it yeah you're
not going to be able to see it from like
an outside perspective and be like you
know what Mark maybe I shouldn't go fly
out to the speaking engagement because
I'm not having a conversation I should
be having with you know a friend or my
wife or something yeah it's definitely
one of those things you realize you
often realize after the fact
um
it's also so hard because
in a lot of cases you have to do too
much and like this has been a common
theme in my life I tend to go too
hardcore on things
to know where that line is like I go
past the line in order to find the line
um so I look back at that period in my
life and it's like yeah I definitely
went too hard I should have like said no
to some things and pulled it back a
little bit
but part of that partly I only know that
because I went too far and I you know in
my case it was during that period of my
life I was you know aside from just
pretty intense burnout and being
dissatisfied
um
my health started to suffer a lot I
gained a ton of weight
um
was like horribly out of shape
felt stressed all the time had sleeping
problems so it's like that's those are
all telltale signs like those are all
signs that your body's telling you yeah
like bro that's interesting because
that's actual like it's a visual one
yeah whereas like a lot of the other
times you know like relationships and
stuff like that it's hard to to see yeah
when they're suffering yeah but if you
do look at your body and you're not
satisfied with where you're at and you
know that you could be sacrificing a
little bit of that for a little bit more
of this but if you don't need but it's
funny because I would say even with
where even
were not objective even with our own
bodies like it it and I'm sure anybody
who's struggled with with their weight
knows this like it's
I I had to go again it was I gained
probably 40 pounds
over like four or five years 40 50
pounds and um
it really wasn't until I was like 40
pounds in and then I was like oh wait I
gained a lot of weight you know like it
was I was years into an unhealthy
lifestyle at that point before it even
occurred to me like oh [__] my jeans
don't fit
I'm curious also what role your wife
played in your success she's great man
honestly
um
she is
the first person that hears any idea I
have
um and we have a very
strong respect for honesty with each
other so I mean she'll if it's a bad
idea she'll be like um
I don't think that's it
um
she's a great sense of
she's great taste not only in men but in
in in Creative work as well in books
yeah so so like she'll look at she'll
look at a bunch of book covers and be
like no no these are bad this one's kind
of good whatever she's great for stuff
like that she's also just I don't know
it's
you know there's all this data that uh
married people make more money and and
you can actually it is and it's pretty
causal like you can see it like you can
see even high achievers
as soon as they get married there's like
an uptick in earnings and I I think
there's so much intangible value of
Simply Having a partner
that can be a sounding board like any
sort of major decision that I I'm
wrestling with
she can be a sounding board like she'll
tell me if my reasoning makes sense if
it doesn't make sense she'll tell me if
I'm being irrational she'll tell me like
if I'm having trouble with employees
she's like an objective third party who
can be like well no actually I think
you're being kind of hard on him
um
there's just so much like intangible
day-to-day value not to mention like the
emotional comfort and the the stability
that comes with with a long-term
relationship
um
but yeah she's she's been incredible I
Love Actually what you said and this is
a metric I am now going to apply on my
future dates or I guess maybe not dates
but like you know life partner is you
need to be able to hear something like I
don't like that idea or hear criticism
from your partner yes uh that is like
one of the I would say the pillars of a
healthy relationship what was the exact
thing that you need to be able to hear
from them just that sucks right or no I
mean it's funny she um
The Stereotype right is like anytime
anytime your wife or girlfriend puts on
an outfit and it's like how do I look
you're supposed to be like wow you look
gorgeous you know I was going to ask you
if you say yes I don't you don't I don't
you say you your hips look big or like
I'll tell her if if she doesn't look
good I'll tell her and she [__] hates
it and but does she ask you I think
that's the difference of you being like
she's funny I don't like that on you
versus like crazy I didn't expect you to
actually say that yeah no she'll she'll
ask for my opinion okay and it's funny
because okay so early in our
relationship she'd get kind of mad and
I'd be like well you asked so I'm gonna
give you my opinion
and then as time went on so first of all
that does a couple things one it just it
it's not comfortable in the moment again
not turning away from hard things but it
breeds so much trust because now she
knows she knows from a very early stage
if I say she looks great she must she
[__] looks great like I'm not
kissing her ass I'm not you know just
trying to be a sweet boyfriend or
whatever like I actually mean it like
wow you are stunning and she gets that
much happier because she knows it's true
and it's honest the funny thing has
started happening I don't know around
the time we got married so like these
days now she'll ask me
should be like what do you think about
this outfit and I'm like
not really feeling it
she's and she'll be like well I love it
so screw you and I'm like okay and so
she'll go out in it anyway so it's like
now we're even at this this like further
level where
she can hear the no
and then she can decide for herself
whether she's gonna take it seriously or
not you know I I have strangely for a
guy who traveled the world and just like
was a chronic womanizer I've I've become
a an unexpected champion of marriage
um
just because I it has been so profound
in my life and unexpectedly profound
like I
if you had asked me when I met her if I
even ever wanted to get married I
probably would have said probably not
like maybe if I have kids but other than
that I don't see any reason how does
marriage differ from a long-term
relationship in my opinion it
psychologically differs quite a bit so
there is
there's a reason the institution has
lost it for like 5 000 years and that is
like you can so when you're with
somebody for a long period of time you
make an explicit commitment you know
it's like okay we're boyfriend
girlfriend we're going to be monogamous
we're these are the expectations of each
other maybe we live together here's how
we're going to share finances you have
all those conversations and so it's like
on the surface level everything is the
same as a marriage the difference with a
marriage is that you
you invite every single person who
matters to both of you in the entire
world you stand in front of them and you
say we are going to share a life
together for the rest of our lives in a
very like emotional ritual
and then it becomes legally binding and
so the social expectation like this
whole layer of social expectation gets
added to it
a legal layer gets added to it and so
there's like you basically ramp up the
psychological constraints on the
relationship massively
which sounds bad but it has had such a
calming effect on me because
there are so many like
minor anxieties that can happen in a
long-term relationship you know it's
like let's say you get in a fight and
your girlfriend like storms out and just
leaves gets her in a car and goes right
all sorts of crazy [__] starts running
through your head you're like where is
she going is she coming back so she
gonna go find a guy is she gonna go to a
bar like what the [__] is she doing
like when you're married you're like all
right yeah
like she has to she [__] she like
literally has to she has to come back
even if it's to divorce you she has to
come back so
um there's something about that and this
comes back to finding
Liberation and constraints like
narrowing down and finding that little
sliver of life and being like this is me
this is who I am and these are the
things I'm going to live for
there's a psychological safety and
comfort that comes with that that is
completely unexpected one way I describe
it to a lot of my guy friends is I say
like
you know when you like leave photoshop
on your computer in the background and
it's like everything else just gets kind
of slow because it's eating up all the
RAM and then you close it and like
suddenly that's why my computer I leave
it open yeah
because I have everything unsaved yeah
that's everything and I don't want to
lose my stuff it's always open it's been
open for like a month so and then you
close it and suddenly your computer is
like try that blazing fast yeah uh so
the way I describe it is there's like
this this program that's open and in the
back of every guy's head which is
where's the hot girl is she into me
what can I do to get her into me you
know and like even even like when I've
been in relationships that window's
still open I'm not clicking on it and
I'm not using it in a relationship but
it's still open I'm like still thinking
about it like I'm in a barn like God
damn
if I was single I wonder what I would
say to her you know like those thoughts
still happen and as soon as I got
engaged it was like that program got got
shut off and all of this mental Ram got
freed up and
I just felt like I had
more
more processing power just more energy
more Focus
there was like no debate it's like okay
this is my person
to [__] ride or die like this whole
subject is just closed case is closed
it's done I never have to think about it
again
I can think about these things that I
really really how much of that is just
making a choice and sticking with it
because you mentioned that before the
Paradox of choice is that you know when
you make that decision now you can focus
on other things do you think it's just
that decision I think that's a huge
component of it
um
I also so the flip side of this too is
that
if you're with the right person and you
have a good relationship with them
this process of adding these constraints
it feels really good because it brings
you guys closer together right so it's
like as you're going through this
process of
getting engaged planning the wedding
doing the wedding
you know figuring out how your life's
gonna function together like it brings
you closer together you feel closer than
you've ever felt before and that you
know if you if you're with the right
person and you love them that feels
really [__] good so you've got this
thing that feels really good that's
happening
and it's like shutting off all this
noise and [__] that you used to
worry about that you don't have to worry
about anymore how do you have a happy
marriage I know it's a deep question but
from your experience what have you
noticed works I've talked about brutal
honesty yeah I think the two most
important factors
and there's like not even a close third
is trust and respect
if trust goes
um nothing else works right it's like if
I don't trust my wife
doesn't matter what she says what she
does
it's not gonna have any value to me
because I'm like why is she doing that
is she like [__] with me is she like
playing me whatever so without trust
nothing nothing else functions and then
without respect
uh
it becomes toxic you you start hurting
each other instead of helping each other
right because if you don't respect the
other person you start trying to impose
your own views and values onto them and
and they try to convince you to take on
their views and values so you end up in
this like power struggle that's really
unhealthy it can be very exciting and
dramatic and the sex can be good but
it's not healthy so trust and respect
have to be there before anything else
um
the other thing about trust and respect
too is
when you have those two things you
realize that it's not about not fighting
like like every couple fights some
couples fight more another some couples
rarely fight some couples fight a lot
but as long as like if you have trust
and respect
you are likely to fight productively
like that's what matters in a
relationship every relationship has
fights every relationship has
disagreements
can you fight productively can you end
up in a better place after the fight
than you were before it
if the answer is yes then that's
probably a good relationship if it's no
it's going to be rough doesn't mean you
can't get there but it's it's gonna be
hard it's like fighting to win the
argument versus fighting to achieve or
land upon some shared objective or goal
that's a huge part of it right because
when people are in uh see the
relationship as a power struggle
every fight becomes I need to be right
you know you need to see it my way and
that's just it's [__] toxic it's it's
just deteriorates everything so
one of the most fundamental parts of
that is saying okay whether I'm right or
wrong
matters less than the fact that we as a
unit are better after this than before
and and our and my marriage like we've
both had multiple times where it's like
[__]
I'm wrong like I mess that up I'm sorry
um and so I think the the ability to
admit that
admit being wrong ask for forgiveness
and then also the ability to forgive
because like a lot of people are able to
say like okay I [__] up I'm sorry A
lot of people are bad at letting it go
like you need to be able to let it go as
well it's like okay it's okay we're
gonna be fine what is your biggest
insecurity and what are certain things
you think you need to work on I'm
hitting middle age and
I'm starting to have a lot of questions
around
like that realization
like not even just thinking about my
mortality but like really a realization
of like okay you might be 50 of the way
through here
Peak years
how are you are you using them well like
how are you using them are you using
them well and so I
I have noticed like I've had a I've had
an urgency
in the last year of like
make sure you're working in on things
and doing things that are going to
matter when you're 80 90 years old I
think it's not enough to Simply know
what you want which a lot of people
struggle to know what they want
you need to also ask yourself why you
want it and be like uncomfortably honest
with that with that question because a
lot of the things that we do want are
driven through insecurity
trauma you know we got bullied when we
were a kid and we think if we have a
Lamborghini like people like us you know
whatever it is
um so be very very brutally honest with
that question of like why do you want
the thing
um in terms of just like improving your
life generally I I honestly think
physical health is underrated I know
that sounds weird to say I don't mean
like [__] dieting and
fads and getting a six-pack I just mean
sleeping well not drinking alcohol
not eating garbage like those three
things right there if you can do those
three things like exercise regularly
even if it's going for a walk like if
you can just do those things
consistently for a few months you will
notice a massive Improvement in energy
and and mood and I think that just gets
underrated like it's not it's not a sexy
answer it's not the ant like it's not a
big life hack that everybody wants to
hear right because it's something that
everyone could be doing at the current
moment it's not like oh get a
Lamborghini oh that's exciting yeah you
know what I mean because you know that
you don't actually have to work a bunch
at this given moment it's like I'm
delaying the burden to My Future Self
yeah but it's like oh you know like
maybe I'll skip out on this cookie or
you know maybe I'll go to the gym wake
up at a certain hour like that stuff you
could be doing right now yeah so it's
not very sexy social relationships is
another unsexy thing that is has
completely outsized benefits on on
happiness
um
it's again there are a bunch of studies
around this it's like I think it was
seeing a good friend once a week was the
equivalent of like
an extra 80k in income in terms of its
effect on happiness levels really yeah I
had no idea there's a bunch of [__] like
marriage is marriage by itself is worth
like I think 200k a year in extra income
in terms of Happiness like it's shocking
how these simple things
have outsized impacts and everybody
continues to ignore them because they're
so boring and put it in so you're saying
you could get hypothetically like 300
Grand a year in happiness by seeing your
friends getting married
exercising on a regular basis
like a very basic thing it's so [__]
boring but yeah
it's probably good and it's absolutely
gonna make you more more happy than the
lambo so that's really interesting can
you rattle off a few of the most
impactful and powerful books that you've
read we already talked about four-hour
work week in the game
uh although I don't know if I would
recommend either of those these days I
think they're both kind of
of a different era
um I'm a big fan of stumbling on
happiness big fan of that book the
roadless travel uh in my opinion that's
kind of like the best classic self-help
book
um
it's a little bit more intellectual but
uh Stephen pinker's the blade the blank
slate changed my views on a lot of
things about like how how much of our
personality and and disposition is
actually alterable and what's not and
that sounds like it's a bad news thing
like we like to believe that we can
change anything about ourselves but I
think actually coming to terms with the
with just kind of how you're naturally
built as a human being is much healthier
just like recognizing like okay I'm an
introvert like let's deal with that
instead of trying to be something you're
not
Jonathan Heights got a great book called
uh the happiness hypothesis which is a
really good review of
uh positive psychology kahneman's book
Thinking Fast and Slow super useful for
understanding just like how bad our
brains are at observing reality
could go on and on it's good yeah a
couple in there I've read a couple I
need to read
um
so one thing that you talked about on
Tom billiard's podcast that I loved was
spiritual entertainment like a spiritual
diet like having that oh it's like
spiritual ice cream for dessert but not
actually do anything for it doing
anything about it yeah um versus actual
self-realization and using like
spiritual enlightenment and applying
that in your life I'm wondering how
could someone go from like a spiritual
diet as though it's just entertaining
like I feel like I'm kind of at the
place where I'm just reading all of
these personal development self-help
type books sure and I'm like well how
much of it am I actually applying in my
real life versus how much do I like that
little cookie at the end of the book
where I'm like oh I feel like I can use
these in my life but I don't actually
use them yeah how do you go from
somebody who just like has that in their
diet versus actually like digesting it
and becoming
self-realized my advice so self-help
there's a certain percentage of
self-help content that really is just
glorified entertainment and there's a
certain percentage of it that
can become a little bit addictive
because that that
people get hooked on that chasing that
feeling of of oh I learned something I'm
improving something I'm better than I
was before I watch this video or look
you know read this book
even though they're not actually
changing their day-to-day behaviors and
when people get kind of caught in that
Loop my recommendation is actually to
just stop like take a month
and this sounds weird but like take a
month and like detox from Life advice
detox like don't listen to podcasts or
read the books or watch the videos like
go 30 days and just live your life just
do things like You're normally doing and
then just pay attention to how happy are
you because in a lot of cases
you're kind of happy already so like
what you don't need to fix what's not
broken I I wrote a number of articles
about this years ago and I talked about
how like in my head there's there's kind
of two versions of self-help and they
don't get distinguished often enough one
is taking people who are in a bad place
and making them okay
and then there's another version which
is taking people who are okay and then
trying to make them better or make them
good or great if you're in a bad place
then yeah you need to work really hard
to get to a place that you're okay but
if you're already in a place that's okay
and you're just like
kind of chronically optimize trying to
optimize every aspect of your life you
can actually drive yourself into a bad
place right because it's like suddenly a
life that is otherwise happy and
successful you're constantly aware of
all the the areas that you're showing up
short and all the things that are
unoptimized and that you're not doing
well enough and so you can drive
yourself into misery that way and so I
always tell people if you feel like
you're at any risk of falling into that
trap just stop for 30 days just go live
and don't worry about it like take a
self-help vacation
what pain do you want in your life and
what are you willing to struggle for
so what pain do you welcome and what are
you willing to struggle for this is your
question you know this it's exactly what
I'm doing like I enjoy
you know I spent about four four or five
years kind of In traditional media doing
a lot of books movies I did a couple TV
deals
coming back to the Creator space where
again I get to have control
um
I create the content I build the team I
scale everything I I figure out
monetization everything it's so [__]
fun like it's stressful of [__] it's an
insane amount of work as you guys know
but
I'm so I'm having so much fun and it's
it feels it feels good it feels like
play and it feels impactful Graham yeah
what pain do you welcome in your life
and what are you willing to struggle for
uh pain I enjoy being the underdog and
changing what I believe could be done
better I don't know if that's quite a
pain
uh jeez pain what discomfort are you
comfortable with and you like I would
say physical exhaustion something that
like for me
like I could lean into that I could
probably do better I could probably
improve on that they're touching myself
there are benefits to that for sure
because that's something I I can't stand
Jack noses I love being comfortable he
is so sensitive to any like we'll go in
a pool that's like not heated I won't
even go it so cold but I feel better
after anything all right so I'm gonna
close this off with a little quote okay
okay there's a quote by you one day it
must be good one day you and everyone
you love will die and Beyond a small
group of people for an extremely brief
period of time little of what you say or
do will even matter this is the
uncomfortable truth of life and
everything you think or do is but an
elaborate avoidance of it we are
inconsequential Cosmic dust bumping and
Milling about on a tiny blue Speck we
imagine our own importance we invent our
purpose we are nothing
that is a quote
thank you very much for coming on the
podcast can I drop this you can't
smash it also huge shout out to
malcolmedia this is their Studio they're
based in Santa Monica they have let us
use this they are so generous so so so
generous I wish I could go on for
minutes about this but I can't if you're
in Los Angeles and you want a studio to
film at and this is not they didn't even
tell us to say any of this did you guys
even do that do you rent out the studio
or is it okay I didn't even know that
we're speaking at us right here
just to get they do if you're in Los
Angeles you want a studio to film that
seriously we can't recommend this enough
this has been like the best shoot this
is even better than our said Jack oh
it's way better and the cameras they
have fx6s which are I mean we have fx3s
so it's at least two times better if my
math is right if this existed in Vegas
we would just be using this instead of
her on set honestly so they're linked
Down Below guys they didn't pay us to
say this we're just doing it as a favor
thank you so much thank you Mark thank
you very much
yeah and uh your books will be linked
down below cool until next time see ya
cool thank you so much man this has been
so good this is fun man